so bleiben noch bei der kriminalität es
dauert nur sekunden und bevor man
überhaupt begriffen hat was da gerade
passiert ist die uhr weg vom handgelenk
weggestoßen blitzschnell manchmal von
einem vorbeifahrenden motorroller aus
räuber die fast wie makler agieren
passiert in vielen urlaubsorten und
insbesondere auch auf mallorca die rolex
banden komplett durchorganisiert denn
dahinter steckt die neapolitanische
camorra
immer öfter schlägt sie zu die
italienische mafia camorra neuestes ziel
der gangster beliebte urlaubsorte auf
mallorca ibiza oder dem spanischen
festland und dort kann es jeden treffen
zumindest wenn man eine luxusuhr ab
20.000 euro aufwärts am arm trägt
rücksichtslos werden dem uhren besitzern
ihre liebsten stücke vom handgelenk
geraubt und das ohne dass es die opfer
gleich merken
auf guardia civil werden täglich drei
bis vier rolex allein auf mallorca
geklaut im juni gelang der polizei dann
einen mini erfolg vier bandenmitglieder
wurden kurz vor abflug am flughafen
verhaftet und so geht die uhren mafia
vor die techniken des uhren klaus lernen
die mitglieder an geheimen orten werden
dann mit gefälschten pässen in die
urlaubsregionen geschleust dann suchen
sich die banden ihre opfer in luxus
leben oder teuren restaurants und
setzten hübsche frauen auf reiche männer
an die ansage der mafia-bosse ohren
unter 20.000 euro lohnen sich nicht ist
eine ur gefunden verfolgt der schwer das
opfer ruft seine bande per handy das
zugriffs kommando führt dann den raub
binnen sekunden durch gibt die uhr an
mittäter weiter und so umfeld es der
polizei dann schwer eine täterschaft
nachzuweisen besonders teure uhren
werden sofort nach der tat außer landes
gebracht wurden unter 50.000 euro tragen
die mafiosi bei der ausreise meist
selbst anhand
[Musik]